what do you think of uh drama channels
what's what's because i i feel like this
that's that's that's a can of work
i feel like there's such a fine line
with drama channels from being like
acceptable to just pure cancer right
it's it's it's such a i wonder who
you're talking about
it's such a it's such a like fine line
to uh to tread right and i think i think
when it comes to drama channels there's
the right way to do it and there's the
wrong way i like scarce is true i was
about to say i think scarce is a drama
channel done right because he merely
states the facts yeah that's it like
then there's there i feel there are too
many drama channels that think that
they're also commentary channels when i
feel those are two very different things
yeah like you could be a drama channel
that like scarce who just states the
facts like this is what happened i don't
want to hear their opinion yeah and then
there are people who are like here's the
drama here's why you should be on that
person's side like that's cancerous yeah
right like just just be like just say
what happened
just state the fact and let the audience
make up their own mind i don't think
there's anything wrong with that to be
honest i think that's why i like the
right opinion as well because at least
like he he does
he does put his opinion in it or like
whenever he's breaking down whatever
drama or whatever that's not the core of
his videos that's not the core of his
video right he's breaking out what's
happening and he he separates that from
his opinion it's it's it's like a clear
divide and that's that's kind of what i
like because you know he allows you to
make up your own mind but then he also
you know he also puts in his own opinion
as well his own perspective and i feel
like that's that's kind of the right way
to go about it and you know
you know even even sometimes there's
might there might be drama channels that
do that but they're also just toxic
personalities as well right and again
like i feel it really does come down to
like the personality of the presenter as
well like if you if you
sell yourself as this kind of like like
you know starting a mob like talk you
know toxic kind of guy who then also
gives your opinion about a certain piece
of drama that
let's be real you're not [ __ ]
involved with yeah you just saw it and
you're like oh dude check check out this
fight that's happening right now let's
let's root for one person right that's
when it becomes toxic but if you're just
like here's what's happening you've
probably heard of it uh here are the
details
make up your own mind yeah yeah it's
like i'm not involved i'm just the
messenger
do what do with it what you will then i
think i think
in a lot of ways
that's fine yeah but again it really
just depends on like how you present it
and how you present yourself yeah this
is why i can never be a drama channel
because i i would just like overthink it
so much that i probably wouldn't even
make the video right so much trauma how
do you keep up with it
that's very exhausting yeah like i like
hot like 99 of that time i just don't
give a [ __ ] honestly one thing that like
we we've talked about toxic anime
fandoms but i think in general
compared to like the other communities
and the other other things going on in
other places i think any tube is like
kind of like chill and drama free i mean
we've had like our drama but compared to
what we've seen elsewhere it's been like
pretty tame yeah it's pretty sure now
yeah i used to not be that chill but i
feel like it's really i feel like even
when it was not that chill it was like
still way more chill than it was it was
way more contained yeah like it wasn't
like the other communities where like
people from other communities would hear
about it but the thing is with
communities right and then
drama is that
it it's you know as much as people want
to unless someone does something really
scandalous like really [ __ ] and that
transcends beyond the community and it's
just so [ __ ] that even like normal
people are like whoa you know that's
that's a rare circumstance but other
than that
the drama in the community is caused and
solely responsible is by like the
biggest creators in the community yeah
if the biggest creators are making drama
in a space then there's drama in that
space yeah you know what i mean like
if we're anime fans and we start doing
something that's really fast we better
watch ourselves then
it's true you know
yeah if there's if
we do something it's it's it's kind of
in the anime community right it's kind
of that would be considered not saying
that we're so big to dramatically but
like when you know the community
is kind of almost dictated at times by
like the biggest people in it oh yeah
yeah and uh that behavior is reflected
downward so if you if you get into [ __ ]
and you say a bunch of [ __ ] yeah the
community's going to kind of mirror that